yeah even brought her daughter date
night with our daughter Wednesday was
family night for John Travolta and Kelly
Preston the couple stepped out for the
FX up front in New York City looking
cute and cozy together on the red carpet
the event celebrated next week's finale
of Travolta show the People vs oj
simpson a role that's earned him
compliments from critics fans and
celebrities like the weekend if he told
me years ago that's the highest critical
acclaim I would have ever got was
playing an older Accenture employer you
know i would say really you know Wow
okay in a new interview with ET the
actor revealed which celebrities praise
has surprised him most Ethan Hart he was
the most articulate of any of the people
i know about how the impact that this
show hat on him and thought it was like
the best thing he'd ever seen season two
of american crime story will center on
Hurricane Katrina and John says both he
and his wife are in I think both Kelly I
would love to be part of that matters
and larimer fun but it doesn't get
better than
naina around so program is just bad team